what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the new crazy one-piece chapter
we learned the fate of luffy and the
straw hats
kaido does something absolutely brutal
and crazy and multiple characters get
epic moments to shine
and more so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these chat
reviews and want to keep them coming
channel the pirate king within and
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one piece videos
lastly while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords supernova and more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all so
this chapter is called
chained and interestingly enough on the
side we're told the struggle against the
emperors reaches its climax
and the climax is defined as the most
intense exciting and important point of
something
in this case of this war against the
yonko
that's a big claim and it makes me
wonder what will happen from here
if we already saw the most intense parts
of this war what i'm hoping is that
they're just click baiting a bit as
shown and do
and they mean we're still around the
beginning of the climax which will last
multiple chapters but we'll find out we
see luffy still in the water and
furthermore we're told he's sinking to
the bottom of the sea
in the meantime people are dealing with
the announcement that luffy lost and is
dead according to kaido
chopper is affected big time as others
visibly panic too
chopper gets bitten as he remarks
there's no
way you actually lost right what are we
supposed to do
now end quote he's crying and i wasn't
sure if any straw hats would actually
get to this point of questioning luffy
but
clearly not everyone is like sanji and
zoro
still if even chopper can be so affected
by the news and thrown off guard
imagine what the newly recruited extras
might be feeling
especially after seeing chopper react
like this people are questioning whether
they lost already and commenting on
kaido's overwhelming dominance
so kaido's plan is working very well
he's done a good job of hurting their
morale
with that announcement and ezo is on the
same page and specifically realizes this
saying and i quote that announcement was
meant to hurt our morale
end quote so immediately it must be
questioned kawamatsu adds
we have no way of verifying it they're
in the right headspace here
they're not jumping to conclusions but
thinking rationally if an announcement
whether true or not
benefits kaido strategically and if they
saw no proof of luffy's death then it
would be stupid to assume all hope is
lost
they have the right attitude of
continuing on as if nothing changed
while sanji is less stoic about it and
angry that so many people around are
dumb enough to lose the will to fight
anyway even though they got no proof of
what kaido is saying
i predicted this would happen with the
extras but the fact that chopper would
be so affected too
shows just how dire the situation
appears as queen mentions chopper was so
fired up earlier that queen played along
but now he's significantly deflated we
also see a bunch of arrows in the men
around queen so clearly pero sparrow has
been
hard at work making it rain candy arrows
pero sparrow comments that when the
general falls
all the pawns lose their composure which
seems like a true enough statement for
the majority of fighters right now he
launches another volley of arrows and
that is an impressive technique
it's insane just how many arrows are
included in that candy shower
still you hope to see him in a real
fight rather than just attacking random
troops
as chopper looks like a deer caught in
the headlights queen calls him cowardly
and prepares to finish him
off but our boy sanji comes to the
rescue kicking queen so hard that his
body spins like
crazy this move is epic for multiple
reasons
some of which include he did this to
kaido's second strongest all-star who's
literally as big as a dinosaur
the attack also managed to deflect all
the arrows shot by pero sparrow and
finally pero sparrow was hurt as well by
the spinning dino helicopter
and sent blasting off like team rocket
for anyone who felt like sanji wasn't
getting his chance to shine
this should make up for it and to boot
after he accomplishes this amazing feat
he acts cool and stoic calmly letting
chopper know he did good
and really pulled through everyone
present remarks that they're saved and
chopper is bawling his eyes out to sanji
about to tell him that luffy is dead and
the calm cool and collected sanji calls
him an
idiot and tells him not to cry saying
they've seen this happen
countless times before and he's so right
many of you usually point out in these
chapter reviews that luffy lost multiple
times
against crocodile in the past and he
straight up looked finished for good in
certain cases
and that's just one example if we had
moments like that with a warlord it
makes sense that we'd have moments like
that with a yonko
sanji has to be my mvp for this chapter
his actions and his dialogue were
amazing
in this one and the effect that he had
on everyone else around him was amazing
as well
he leaves the mummified zorro to chopper
and mentions that if he recovers
he'll be worth 10 men while zoro
hilariously retorts and i quote
more like 2 000 i appreciate these
little humorous moments so much
especially between sanji and zoro
and now that zoro is in chopper's hands
you can bet that he'll be ready to fight
again
before this war is over sanji looking so
cool
says lead the dino to me while an
irritated queen
remarks so it's judges brat this is the
match up i wanted
we knew that chopper wasn't going to
beat queen but sanji beating kaido's
second best commander would be perfect
and really helped position the straw
hats as a formidable crew even compared
to the other yonko crews
and as i mentioned sanji is also helping
to encourage others
as onlookers wonder how he can keep
going after his captain died
marco for his part is just amused and
remarks that that's why he likes the
straw hats
and yeah you gotta admit the straw hats
are awesome we then
jump to the castle interior first floor
kundra and kiku appear lifeless on the
ground
kaido approaches a heavily injured but
still breathing kinemon the attack we
saw last chapter didn't finish him off
but he's definitely in no position to
fight back as momo cries
we get some really touching flashbacks
here as we see how momo and kinemon were
pretty much like father and son
although momo only called him father to
help hide his identity kinemon
was the present father figure for most
of the story and they clearly cared
deeply for each other
as we can tell from the sheer joy they
got at calling out to each other and
being reunited there's no doubt that
kinemon would gladly sacrifice
his life for momo he's not just
sacrificing himself for his ruler but
also for his adopted son in a way
we then get a stark contrast from the
happy flashbacks to the tragic present
where kinemon is badly hurt and
preparing to meet his
end his last thought is not for himself
but for momo
begging him to escape and for shinobu to
keep running
it's a touching eye-watering moment
kinemon was a good man
right up to the end and kaido appears to
finish him off for
good with a sword and you never know for
certain if someone is gone for
good in one piece but this seems about
as final as you can get
and although kaido seemingly takes his
life the yonko appears to respect the
samurai
he tells him to embrace his honorable
death like a true samurai
and that's something that has stood out
with kaido although he can arguably be
evil he does have this respect for
honorable warriors just as he did for
odin it serves to make him a more
interesting antagonist but
wow the scabbards really appear to be
dropping like flies at this point
but it still hits you right in the feels
especially this moment with kinemon and
now props to momo here i already gave my
mvp
of the chapter to my boy sanji but
arguably momo could get it here with his
actions
he's crushed by what he just saw and yet
he still is smart enough and brave
enough to have grabbed the frog
so he can make an announcement of his
own to everyone it seems that when his
head hurt
it was luffy sending him a message we
know momo has the special ability to
sense people from a distance but i'm
more intrigued by luffy's ability here
to apparently communicate like this
momo relays the message that luffy is
still alive to everyone with tears
streaming down his face
he tells everyone that luffy said he
would definitely make it back so keep
fighting even if it hurts and even if
you have nothing left he begs them to
keep fighting until their last
breath although we'll probably learn
more about this in the future right now
it seems that luffy despite being in the
water
communicated to momo that he's going to
beat kaido
and momo lets everyone know that luffy
is going to win then we get a goosebump
inducing moment
where everyone cheers in unison and the
morale is at 100
once again such an amazing moment for
luffy and i really look forward to
finding out more about the implications
of this ability to straight up
communicate with momo to the point where
his head aches unbearably but also with
others as we'll see in a bit but we also
have to hand it to momo
kaido must be impressed by how much this
one kid can influence the entire battle
just as kaido's announcement
strategically served to kill morale momo
arguably boosted morale higher than ever
before with his own announcement
he truly is already an amazing leader
especially because he was able to do
this
on the spot right after witnessing his
father figure die before his
eyes now that's two dads he's lost to
kaido so i'm hoping he gets some
satisfying revenge against him before
this is all through
now if i understood these panels
correctly as kaido has cornered shinobu
and momo
shinobu apparently uses her ability to
decay the ground beneath them
so that they begin to fall straight off
the island to kaido's surprise
and that might really be the best bet
they have at this point and then one of
the many theories that was suggested in
the comments section of the last video
proved to be correct i saw a bunch of
theories in the comments for how luffy
will be saved including this one which
makes a lot of sense
while a submarine stumbles upon luffy
and his crew recognize luffy
but perhaps stumble is not the right
word because they say
it's like they could hear his voice even
though they're underwater
the voice of all things ability has been
very strong in this chapter
and luffy is not just hearing voices but
apparently his ability to communicate
his own voice to others is absolutely
amazing
and i love that you can't say it was a
coincidence or that he got
lucky because his voice no doubt called
them here
even though they're confused about the
whole thing another
interesting development we see is that
zeus appears to be
inside nami's weather weapon now we
quickly gloss over this part in this
chapter but another great detail
since you all know how much i wanted the
nami and zeus combination
and i'm so glad we appear to have gotten
it the exact explanation of what exactly
is going on can wait of course
as we jump to kit and law confronting
big mom
although big mom thought it was over
when luffy hit the water
law knows that when it comes to luffy
never say never and although kid talks
big like law will only get in the way as
he finishes off a yonko
law is like bro we should play nice for
now and he's got a point with luffy out
of the picture even if only temporarily
they gotta do what they can to make sure
they win
the last thing they should do is get
more divided and conquered
lastly we get such a hype match-up
yamato finally calls out kaido as they
prepare to fight and obviously yamato
showing up and distracting kaido
prevents him from even
trying to look for momonosuke and
shinobu if he wanted to although kaido
wants her to call him father
she says that bond a father and daughter
has chained her for too long
and she's going to free herself from it
although i don't think yamato has a
chance to beat kaido physically it will
be interesting to see how fighting his
own child may affect kaido
psychologically and even if yamato loses
and only buys some time
it'll no doubt be significant that she
was able to put it all on the line here
without holding back
come what may and that's it for this
insane chapter
while reading it back i'm shocked at how
much happened
in just one chapter we got no break next
week
either so we're going very strong right
now
as always let me know your thoughts on
this chapter and what you expect to see
happening next
who was your mvp this time around i love
the sanji moments the momo moments
and of course the luffy moments but i
think it's about time my boy sanji gets
mvp for this one
if you do enjoy these chapter reviews
and want to keep them coming channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss
future one piece videos lastly while you
wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all the yonko
warlord supernova and much more link to
that is in the description
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you